hey what's happening thanks for tuning
in to another episode about to be talked
I got a fantastic guest today introduced
yourself man I'm a Paul from the band
st. Paul and broken bones we don't get a
last name oh yeah I do Paul Janeway from
st. Paul a broken bones so [ __ ] great
to have you man I am it's funny I first
of all I love you been oh good I love
you Band I love you and I I've seen
probably over a couple thousand concerts
in my life and I really remember
specifically you know I'm a huge on big
guy and I saw Terence Trent d'Arby on
the big on the big record the first one
yeah then I also saw him on the vibrator
record now the vibrator record would not
very many people know that record and I
saw him at the fillmore and there's
probably only if this is long after his
fame a couple other people and it was
hands down the best frontman I'd ever
seen yeah and I seen prince and I think
princes oh yeah on the top that's
absolutely same prints many times but
this was something I still cannot
believe and the reason i bring that up
was a couple years ago I get turned down
to your record people know I love R&B
like I I love Otis I love early stuff
you know also the 70 step Curtis
Mayfield yeah god to me yeah Earth Wind
and Fire my point is I get your record I
go see at the El Rey and it was one of
the best shows I've ever seen oh thanks
man and it was probably like you're like
we sucked at not yeah we're horrible
that night I'm like just go with it man
yeah but you are exactly what I I played
music for years 25 years and you're
exactly the flavor that I also love
because I always had a dream of having
an R&B band but it was hard to find that
kind of players and it takes a serious
serious long commitment and journey
absolutely you know what I mean to you
and also for people to get that style
you
you know like I don't know if it was
easier for you to find that kind of
those players and stuff and understand
the dynamics and that kind of thing and
really like what got me going back on it
was Curtis Mayfield that box set came
out and also Lenny Kravitz mama said
record he had a lot of false ad you know
so many teams you to hang in there and
he covered Billy Jack there was an era
of that and then Terrance and prints and
all that that I just go crazy right you
know how does it happen for you of
course church yeah yeah i mean the
church thing of course I grew up I grew
up around that I mean for me it was as
well as things that I always always
wanted to do that that's what I was my
natural fit always right it was also
when those things I'm not an incredibly
social person so I didn't know a lot of
people right and I'm like a nerd yeah I
mommy yes was when I look at yeah I
think this guy was definitely a nerd but
he would explode in his room on his
anxiety I mean I think the whole band
we're just a bunch of nerds that I
really loved music and especially are
being also and we grew up on it you know
I mean you know half the guys are from
muscle shoals area we had the swampers
and all that great stuff and then you
know me and Jesse became really good
friends he's a bass player and we just
love music but it was always something I
wanted to do and he knew everybody he
knew all the players he knew what he
wanted to do and and I said the only
thing more requirement is that this
won't be in a band with horns yeah and
so that's kind of what happened we just
go immediately said I don't want to make
any money yeah let's kill about nine
dudes in this bed and split a girl right
yeah yeah that's uh that's exactly what
we did it was not I was a it was crazy
cuz you know when people people you play
clubs and things seem they ain't see no
damn you know eight-piece band no get up
there and do that and they're like like
I don't know where to put y'all so
there'd be times I'd be on top of bars
up you had to learn it and so it was fun
it's a good time and yeah no money for
sure no and and and I've never played
music or
did comedy for money ever to me to find
the right guys like you have would give
me such a [ __ ] a wealth in happiness
that I wouldn't give a [ __ ] about money
but you you need every guy on the same
page like whoa we're going to play this
style of music word probably 99.9 going
to make zero money but you know what
when we go out we're going to show
people stuff that they aren't going to
see ya probably ever you know in this
world of you know pre-recorded and taped
and and one guy you know it in in in the
world aren't be in the world to people
is just hip-hop which is ridiculous it
is it is to me growing up it was earth
wind and fire was lakeside it was it was
Curtis Mayfield it was Otis Redding it
was uh you know all this stuff in the
seventies uh James Brown I went through
ugh James Brown phase about two years
who I could as we all do yeah right yeah
I remember getting that a live live live
or whatever Paris and I was a listen to
this band it was my dream you know JB's
man that's that's it I mean I think you
know people talk about greatest American
bands and you know you got the JB's you
got booker t mg you know you got the
swampers I cuts the meters that's who I
think I don't laters yeah I don't think
anybody else but but then yeah you know
it's funny because when I saw Neil Young
did a tour with Booker T am Jesus is
backup band really when you oh yeah you
could I got it on bootleg you can I saw
it at the shoreline you kind of think
you can YouTube it it made southern man
and all these great songs so different
and cruel you're like listen to this
yeah it was unbelievable yeah that's
cool it really is cool now well old are
you I'm 33 i just turned 33 I guess what
a couple days ago oh happy birthday
thanks man very cool yeah and before
because I watched an interview with you
and you
I said well [ __ ] it we're over let's
just make that last kind of demo and go
to college and this will just be fun for
us right before you make this demo which
I assume our songs on the first record
were you playing any other styles
growing up did you ever try to play rock
music like hey let's be like girl grunge
band hey we ever into Oasis whatever cuz
I try to picture you're like I can't
picture you ever been up there like
being like the strokes or something no I
i I'm not cool enough I don't think I'm
uh I think for me I I this was the
second band i've ever been in I mean go
office Lee singing in church and light
and [ __ ] like that like I did that a lot
and then the the first band I was ever
in with it was actually how I met Jesse
who's the bass player right and I was
just happy to be in a band and I didn't
you know it's weird i know people find
this weird brian grow up listening to
Led Zeppelin or any though or anything I
never I didn't know much about it why is
that was it a church family strict yes I
will direct and then and then eventually
it was just kind of like you hadn't
listened to it but then you know I hit
about 18 19 it was just the door flung
open yeah I was into I mean just
devouring everything and haven't really
stopped since because I still feel like
I'm playing catch-up you know um cuz
you're in the south which is huge
classic rock world da hell right you're
not listening the radio was it a rule
house yeah it's not what's in the radio
not here and and all I mean to be fair
it wasn't like I was uber rebellious or
anything like that I hated school but
that was about it for me Hannah but you
know I did I did what I was told church
doors are open i was in there and family
are they part of the church are there
like they were they worth the time as
anything else you know you get older you
grow and you get a little more life
experience and I that [ __ ] kind of you
know kind of I don't want to say fades
away just you your mind opens up a
little bit more it's funny you say that
because i was just in North Carolina all
week doing shows as first time doing
shows in the bible belt and I say that I
say that I think that kids had the
internet now and they're gonna make
their own decision
and everything but it didn't seem like
that to me at all it just seemed like
it's our way and whatever you say is
wrong beyond I mean yeah it's really
interesting in the world of choose for
yourself yeah it's it's an interesting
way to grow up mom you would think oh we
have all this exposure now and the site
well that's not to me it's one of those
things it's a family and in your
surroundings still a very important man
what's the old saying like you marry the
girl that's that you know within a
ten-mile right yeah yeah you know that's
and that's true i mean in that in that
way that's that's how it works and i
think for me it was a situation where
you just kind of fall out of love with
that because I'm I'm i would probably
consider myself a fairly liberal guy
yeah yeah it's funny cuz when I look at
you I think you're already married right
and you grew up in the church world and
I looked I don't drink I've never had a
I also alcohol either so I'm oh I'm a
weird I still have a weird guy yeah
you're not really though because I know
a lot of guys that don't drink and you
can keep it together you know but I get
it you know you didn't repeal like
junior high and sneak off a smoke weed
or anything no nothing I was in the
church in church I was I was the janitor
at the church I was preaching at the
church wow that was I was it's it's it's
a bizarre thing for me because I never
thought that would I meant it's not this
how was ya you know because I've never
had cousins who you know that it was
like they did that they'd go you know
sneak off smoke some weed and go in the
woods in the tent and get you know get
messed up and like I I was like oh
that's not me i want to be a preacher I
want to do this is what I have to the
life Wow and like the Sam Kinison of
rock I guess so in a way yeah oh bizarre
and you were really any of that because
I look at that also is performing
absolutely some of the biggest
evangelists I think what they have going
for them and even if you look back at
some of the crazy ones like Jim Jones
and that guy anything and everything is
they really can pick up on how to guide
people through their performance
I watched you perform I was electrified
and I see a lot of front man and I
consider myself an okay front like I owe
you do stand up so that yeah that's the
ultimate that is that's the scariest
thing out there I mean fur because for
me I'm hot behind the band if something
goes wrong yeah you ain't got [ __ ] the
hot behind you just got it and then you
get all the glory there's are those
things you know it's it's it's a balance
but uh ya know that's that's I mean
churches where you learn that you learn
to read an audience and be big and small
exactly dynamics is church to me and i
cannot hear you out there and then you
bring it all the way down like it comes
into your land yeah you're just like
yeah yeah I can hear you man
mountaintops and valleys low and that's
what you do it's how we set the setlist
up Wow like up to take them up and down
yeah because you going on you want
people you want people at the same show
to be able to cry and to be able to
laugh that's what you want isn't and and
and that's that's the whole point that's
it's all about creating that moment and
that them for anything for any
performance it's about that connection
with the audience that you go wow this
is it this is if I could bottle this up
I'd never leave my house yeah I can and
that's that's the whole point for us any
show we ever play is that right there is
to bottle that up to create that moment
where it is almost like I mean you know
you talk about prints or seeing somebody
live yeah it's what it's about it's
about that kind of y'all most like that
was that a religious moment I just had
it's true and it's it's it doesn't
happen every show no that's funny to say
that because I was just telling a friend
of mine he said you know like hey you
know you prayed a lot of music what was
your best gig as music yeah because a
tour with a lot of people and I put you
know thousands of gigs right and I said
you know what's funny is like out of the
couple thousand gigs i put music i've
probably had five out-of-body
experiences where it's so magic that you
came [ __ ] bullet you step on stage or
like are we done you came but yeah and
with comedy I've done over 3,000 shows
now oh yeah i know in seven years
contained in 25 years I've had hundreds
of those kicks
yeah out of the body so to me it like
you said it doesn't happen every show I
feel that's because you have so many
pieces that have to all be in place the
horn guys got to be having the drummer
is in the bass player no one ever goes
out of tune the sound system is perfect
the venue's perfect the light you know
what I mean yeah there's so many things
that involved but with comedy it's me
the mic in the crowd so there's so much
like possibility of next level magick
you know yeah absolutely i mean it's
that that tingly feeling from your head
to your toes and when look at you can
see it in everybody's I you know the
band and the audience and you're just
like this is a moment I don't know what
it is yeah and it we're lucky enough to
you know I've had it happen with you
know 20 people in the audience and I've
had it happen you know with with two
thousand and I think that's the thing
man it's just that's what's about stymie
I I don't know but that's why I perform
I mean is that to get that model of
doing and I'm get that moment absolutely
right yeah it doesn't matter if there's
20 as cliches that it is it matters for
the tour bus gas money exactly but other
than that man like I never shortchange a
small crowd like I don't go he's just 20
let's just do 10 songs and get out of
here I get it to them because i was 20
are gonna leave and go man we saw the
greatest show and next time you come
through word of mouth grassroots yeah
that's cool yeah that's that's that's
our approach to that's how we approach
we're very old school in the way we
approach things it's like if there's 20
people there give them the damn show
their life yeah make them never forget
it and that's that's the goal every time
now I've got to give hats off I don't
know um who your record company is who's
it right now it's songs songs are
records sorry records is the name of
that hahaha that is actually the name of
the company well who signed you for the
first record a single lock in muscle
shoals they actually good friends of
ours they got us for the first record
cuz that is to to sign a band like you
guys
you immediately have to think there's no
money going to be here we're not going
to get any radio play kids aren't gonna
like it yeah and it's not going to be an
easy cash in and and what I saw from
that was I don't know how I i found out
i think it was a YouTube video those
ones where you guys were in the
warehouse oh yeah yeah I was like I
remember specifically the town I clicked
on it it was broken bones and pocket
change yeah and I was like are you
[ __ ] kidding this is to me one of the
best songs I've heard in 20 years Oh for
me that is like it has everything you
wanted a song it's got great lyrics it
has a full drama theme yeah yeah it
[ __ ] comes on like try a little
tenderness yeah yeah I mean and it grabs
me right away I go I'm [ __ ] in yeah
and then I start watching all these
videos what I'm trying to say is whoever
was pumping knew there was a shitload of
pro shot stuff yeah you know early on
well I mean I think the thing was is
that they I think we all knew all right
the Records the records the record and
you know at the time we made that record
it was we were only a band for six
months yeah for four or five months how
long it take to track the record yeah we
took basically it was the bet we
basically just by my vocal take really
look at the the best of the three vocal
to invest we'd play it three times we're
not top yeah that money then that Tom's
way to attract or digital what was
always the toy we did it on the analog
we did on tape yeah we're up in a up in
muscle shoals or Sheffield Alabama
called a place called nut house and then
we mixed it at fame right which is the
famous famous studio though wow so you
go in you guys set up and you just track
it in a weekend that's basically how
good the [ __ ] out house how we did it
Wow we were like well that's how they
did it so yeah oh let's see if we can do
it cuz we're like that's that's a band
to me is not worth their salt if they
can't go in there and do something
respectable like that which you know I
mean there's a lot of bands that don't
place yet live anymore
ninety-nine percent I mean come on I'm
not here to [ __ ] on the business no no
no but I said this many times people and
I love Adele I don't like her new record
I think it was that record is no good
yeah and then people are just gonna love
it and I love her so I'm not shitty not
now yeah I just allenton for sure I
think the chasing pavement record and
the next record are masterpieces but
what I'm trying to get to is people were
like can you hear her sing can you
[ __ ] imagine this and I go you know
what that's how everyone used to be
right yeah and it's so it's so bad now
that when someone has talent you're like
holy [ __ ] look at this I always feel
that the record company people are like
don't push this they're gonna want more
talent you know what I mean yeah I'm
gonna want more of this and we're gonna
be [ __ ] man we just want to get this
garbage out there and then get on to the
next garbage well and I've got the same
way with you guys yeah when people say
man can you believe how he sings I go
yeah I can't believe it because why
don't you go back and listen to where
he's getting this from solutely he took
the [ __ ] right steps he wasn't
listening to [ __ ] you know hip-hop or
samples or or brother Sinkin right he
was listening to live vocals yeah you
know that's I mean that's to me is I we
do feel uh it's kind of a lost art yeah
a lot of ways and and there are the good
thing is there are people i think
personally there are people there is an
audience for it i think they're people
that are really like you know what kind
of tired of same ol [ __ ] and the same
old like all right here you know they
have it down and this is no joke they
have it down to an algorithm yeah they
have been to do yeah yeah for real like
that it's a mathematical process
absolutely for pop music and you're like
you got to be kidding it's gross then
that's close to me that's like that's
like it I if you know it's like I think
I think we're going to look at like the
auto-tune vocoder yeah period the same
way is that maybe we look at like hair
metal or certain things because it
doesn't age well yeah yeah you know
there was
a time where I just felt they had a
warehouse out and bake in Burbank where
they just had hip hop props some cars
with rims and chains and and and naked
women and and bottles to pop that were
like you know like dawn perry on and i
thought to me it just seemed like next
guy and the guy come in they throw this
[ __ ] on as I boom ya got the rims
[ __ ] come on you know the air
and the next guy different hat tilted to
the side outfit different car yeah and
spinners we had spinners now you know it
was just the same videos over and over
and I love some hip hop me too yeah but
but it's the same thing that's this
that's that's the same thing like the
even in that realm everywhere yeah
there's this manufactured [ __ ] that
you just kind of like you're like man
and you would like to think oh well that
doesn't have any lasting value but it
does oh god yeah you know the main and
so it bums you out a little bit but you
just I mean our whole thing is is like
we do what we do you don't like it sorry
yeah you know that's why I go on to a
lot like with my comedy yeah you know
I'm not gonna go do a cruise ship and
just check it I mean hey you can come do
this room but you can't say this NAT I'm
like well you got the wrong guy right
exactly i just get another guy there's a
lot of those guys out there really get
me know yeah now when you start a first
i didn't hear the answer to the question
your first band was it different
sounding where you guys yeah i mean
without it was uh it was still my voice
but they wanted to do we did like
Zeppelin covers Wow and stuff like that
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] well give me some ma I
mean like a big a long time oh no give
me like
tasting control I can't man I've our kid
do it right now oh yeah rubber plant man
it just imagine I've been boosting
confused yeah I uh I I loved well Jessie
told me he said the reason the reason
that he did is it he didn't he's never
had a friend that could actually like do
it yeah and I didn't know any I didn't
know any Zeppelin yeah it was so I
didn't I know it's crazy but I did and
we would do that I mean we would write a
few of our own things just a cover band
in the bar circle it was it was we did
we did our own stuff i mean we wrote our
own stuff it was a little weird kind of
quirky little more rock and it was
really weird and it wasn't really geared
around my voice but I was just happy to
have friends yeah yeah and to into like
like be playing music are you parents
like hey that's the devil right there I
know my parents have grow up my parents
have grown just like anybody else does
and I think they're uh I think I think
at first especially with this they're
kind of car you know my dad works for
paving and construction company oh yeah
so the whole I collar guy yeah yeah I
mean as you know my mom knows worked for
she's a nurse yeah that's that's just
you know there's there's a thing about
putting your head down and grinding it
out and working and working for family
and things and so which I apply to this
yeah I thought but it I think when this
first started they were all kind of like
when you get when you go on your
vacation yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly and
then we still joke about it like we'll
see family nearby all right well when
you go get a real job how about you hi
this is one that makes my skin crawl
it's Thanksgiving you still doing that
muse oh that music thing yeah still do a
guy just said that to me at a couple
days ago yes this [ __ ] guy makes my
[ __ ] skis I can manager in the
business you know and he said still
doing that comedy thing I was like yeah
yeah just like 3,000 people this week
you know carolina theatre just got 3,000
chains yeah still doing that comedy
thing this looking guy man there's only
there's only yeah there's only one
one I guess a job that I encountered
that I want to play no no this is legit
and its people that cut my hair at
sports clips oh they don't believe that
like somebody comes in here that sports
clips it's good to get their hair cut
and the woman's always like oh yeah you
do music and you're like well what do
you really do it's like no damn it this
is for real I tore the damn wall doing
this yeah you know and people are now
people don't ask you then it's Beyonce a
Down executing stone exactly that's
what's out there exactly exactly and
you're like no no I make a look this is
what I do for living yeah and and it's
that it's always the one it's the one
job that's the only time like no we've
opened up for own stones you know what I
mean unbelievable you know what I mean
no it's it's so funny that's the only
time that I get I start trying to like
puff my chest out yeah yeah I don't care
from there but apparently it's the lady
cutting my hair at the sports clips I
work for the stones for four years
traveled the world with them Oh 2206
awesome yeah and one thing I worship
about them is they have obviously really
hip kids because I know that Jagger
probably goes like here should we get
this year on to it you know yeah because
the years i was out it was like the
white stripes The Strokes the gay a yes
Black Eyed Peas uh most lonely but
whoever was kind of hip at the time they
would have do a few gigs yeah it's an
interesting way that you get to take a
picture with the band right there you
line up right here the band's going to
walk by they're going to take a picture
and then they're gonna get unseat
exactly I love that because people like
you know a way back there just doing
weed with [ __ ] Jew keeping stairs
like naw man it ain't like today like
called a [ __ ] business bingo
oh yeah that was when we did it we got
to open up for him we did you get to
sing a song with Jagger I did not damn
it is he a josh Stone would come out oh
no I know well we didn't know you smoked
him out love i love Jagger I know I know
I was but he was Frank don't bring that
kid up ya know he it was really funny
because we got to do two shows with them
and we're at we did we got to do Atlanta
oh yeah at the Georgia Tech football
stadium killer and then we did a dog is
that the Bulldogs that's a Yellow
Jackets Yellow Jackets yes yellow Jack
Georgia Tech Georgia Tech I got you yeah
I know someone Walter Payton prayed for
her Herschel Walker Schwalger play for
Georgia that's in Athens I got children
anyway and then we did a European tour
then came back and did Buffalo New York
at the Buffalo Bill stay oh and it was a
it was I was an humble it was funny
because a woman comes in our dressing
room says Paul here I said I'm Paul and
she she said come with me and I'm about
halfway down the elevator my hey what am
I going to do she's like well Keith and
the guys wanna hang out right yeah so I
was like so you're going into the
rattlesnake lon I didn't even know I
don't know what to expect you know cuz
you hear stories yeah and and but my
first thought wasn't like holy [ __ ] i'm
about to go meet the rolling stones I
know my first thought was if the band
does not get to meet these guys I will
never live this down you're so right
yeah yeah no it's all about you now like
print some purple rain ya know the
puppet exactly exactly that's exactly so
the I said hey is the band gonna get to
meet him she's like oh yeah this they
just wonder they just won't say hello so
go down and hang out and and it's just a
plant snooker yes no current and case in
there and he he spills a drink on my
foot well I don't even like yeah we
don't even we don't even doesn't even
acknowledge it nope no no he's like he
did it on purpose to see ya there was a
test yeah I probably was a test of some
sort but and I was you know I don't care
I'm like I'm still kind of you know in
shock at the mall are you framing them
yeah right oh my wife made those shoes
and then Keith spilled wine on
exactly exactly and it was just a crazy
experience and got to hang out with
Ronnie and Charlie and an inmate came in
there for a little bit and it was uh it
was a was an incredible it was
incredible day remember the day he got
the called out for him how did that
happen this is what is crazy is it is a
weird circumstance of that we play
Coachella which he knows got huge
festival and I'm so apparently the AEG
the big old concert promoters you know
they're doing the stones to her and one
of the guys I guess one they had had
guys there one big big big boobs was
there and he I think they were there to
see somebody else right not like Alabama
Shakes or some something somebody else
and they they and I think of young
internals I hey go check out this band I
think y'all might like it and uh anyway
so I get offstage and a guy goes a hey
I'm you know blah blah blah blah he said
how would you like open up for all
stones wow he just comes with the office
I'd like to a famous it I said I said uh
uh uh I'll laughs yeah oh yeah you sure
you know you tell Keith and Mick yeah I
had an open up gonna coach shell in the
desert here you might want to get some
water dude he's not out here I had no
you know he had he had like a you know
shorts and a button up or whatever was
like who the hell's one of those [ __ ]
dust mask yeah like who the hell's this
guy so anyway we I get in the van you
know we're going we're actually that's
when we started writing a new record
right and I get in the van and I tell
the guys i said hey you'll never believe
this [ __ ] yeah this guy said how would
y'all feel about open the girls doesn't
we all we all laugh yeah all laugh so
inside do you think maybe it's true or
who yeah yeah well so no no when I
googled the guy yeah I was like haha
right this guy might not be full of [ __ ]
yeah and I
yeah then they then our manager a couple
couple weeks later said she was she was
over the moon and it was it was I mean
like I said it's something I told the
guys before we played the first show
said this is written on bands grace now
yeah i mean i look at the meters by oh
and one thing that's mentioned opening
up for the Rolling Stones same with her
uh uh leonard skinner yeah you know i
mean it's just one of those weird things
and so um guns and roses too yeah back
in the day I remember axel said we're
gonna open for the stones and they said
well they broke up because that was
after tattoo you that's never gonna how
many oz oh it's going to happen and
[ __ ] look at steel wheels or whatever
tour yeah 89 boom they're [ __ ] to
open and focus I'm saying it's one of
those things is just you can't like all
the people all the people that you know
especially in our hometown there you
know you you know how people get jealous
yeah and ricotta yeah you know and so
for us it was like that you couldn't you
couldn't mess with that that was like
you're done they're like is like you did
that like and so it's that's the serious
see you later yeah what [ __ ] yeah
yeah even if we didn't play again in
this small town I live in it'll always
be I'm the only guy in this town they
don't spot well drinks on you guys yeah
exactly yeah no it was but it was one of
those things is just like all right you
can't nobody can take that away from
them and you have moments like that
where you're like nobody can take this
away from you and you've worked your ass
off and it does and it's all about you
people work their ass off and you know
it's about luck timing and our work and
that's that's that's the combination and
you just can't predict it it's hard work
is what it is yeah and and and son write
it now people understand you got to have
songs I've seen a million people sing
you know I think the voice was a very
very bad thing for singers to show the
world yeah because once Christina
Aguilera's is out uh people think it's
all about vocal acrobats yeah yeah
which is zero because zero soul here to
me yeah zua so and and then people are
gum in a way where they're like God how
great is she it's like well there's 90
of those at the rehearse a night and
Christina yeah I'm not taking any where
thing away from her yeah what I'm
talking about is everybody that wanted
to be that after and and just and it
just became acrobats and not soul and
and feeling and also phrasing and and
the way that your timing is and
everything it's so [ __ ] hard to sing
like that people don't know to you know
like like the commitments to me the
movie right when that guy comes on I was
like could be the best singer I've seen
you know in years right and and and you
that's a lot of natural stuff do you
remember the first time that you sang
how did you know that you had that when
you just singing to like old Otis
Redding records and stuff because the
timing and everything you know um I
never thought I was much of a singer to
be fair that's crazy I mean I like in
the car I used to sing you know and I
started to get it you know I'd like
urgent emergency yeah I mean yeah I
could do it a little yeah yeah yeah do
this if the [ __ ] stare was a little
low right be I urge you know the first
time you hear vocals so lit up oh yeah
let's listen it might be a little pitchy
call to call but that's the humiliate ur
gay ur gay men put the band back in
exactly exactly no that's that's the
humiliate her button how does it happen
is it in church i'm at i guess so III
never actually was bazaars i had a
pastor at the time and he was just
really about humility yeah and humbling
you know and then being humble and i
knew i was like man I really love
performing I really love singing but I
think his idea was I think he was coming
in it from a good place but was to keep
me humble right you know what I mean and
so I never thought was he saying you're
not that good yeah
just kind of put me you know and he's
like that guy not my temper exactly
y'all's great movie you know it's funny
about that is I've worked with some
producers and they ride the [ __ ] out of
him yeah and also in comedy I had a
comic I look up to and I was doing
really good the first couple years and
then in the hall he said yeah you that's
some [ __ ] material up there did I
get way funnier in the hallway and that
that helped me yeah like maybe your
pastor you know he's letting you know
yeah you got some but you're not like
you know exactly and i think i think you
know to be fair I think that helps me
now cuz i don't i don't feel like oh
I've arrived I mean obviously I'm making
a living doing this yeah there's still
things i wanna i mean i don't i'm not
worried about some modern singer there's
no modern singer that I look at and go
you know I'm a competitive guy I saw you
say that yeah I'm a competitive human
being you have to be also i think in in
in the arts in a little bit of way to
its its I don't think competitive is the
right word I think it's drive drive and
and the competition makes your drive
right eventually you get somewhere and
you go oh yeah I'm cool with her you
know them yeah but you need that drive
to get you to write and work and perform
yeah and I think yeah and and to me but
I it's the Giants it's the Marvin Gaye's
yeah it's Redding's and those those are
the singers that's dumbing Marvin Gaye
said any goal of any singer and I think
any goal of any performers immortality
yeah and if you don't think that then
don't put your [ __ ] out there yeah you
know and that's not that's not trying to
be like you know whatever but that that
we don't do that there's a drive to for
for perfection and for em to be and to
be great yeah that's the name is brown
yeah my favorite clip is when he when
he's busted into Bootsy Collins for five
bucks you know it's like he's spinning
around he's like oh no
yeah and he is right here's what he's
gonna find that his own didn't know I
got you you know I gotcha you tomz him
as that means 10 he got me two times cuz
he missed two David no yeah honey it's
like you know yeah uh was he crazy
perfectionist absolutely and does his
music sit around forever and stand the
test of time it's like that famous thing
when you die like Jim Morrison said when
they make a movie about you yeah yeah i
mean and i when i played music I always
always could hear the sounds in my head
I always wanted to be Lenny Kravitz kind
of soul meets mother love bone yeah you
know what I mean I mean I just loved
guys you know Elton John I know songs
man but also soul yeah I know even some
of that blind melon yeah Tony home
absolutely yeah I mean there was some
soul going on yes I think that's
absolutely man I you know I think that's
true I think that's I mean not to not to
sound whatever but you know I actually
bizarrely elton john is a huge fan of
ours oh wow and so he but he dude dude
knows more soul than anyone I've ever
met well he's a record gut inside the
Tower Records movie he was there every
tuesday morning he he is such a it was
insane turning me on to [ __ ] you never
heard of her yeah i mean this just
insane and so he actually one of the
nicest things he gave me a old 45 of
this singer and we had talked about and
and who was it it's a thing his name I
Kylie I can't members name is Darren doc
he remember the last name but it was a
you would hear it you think I said
that's a female singing right and it was
it was a male yeah and he was just
amazing his knowledge is just I just
blown away blown away but he's smart you
know to me but you but you can tell a
lot of those guys that's what they're I
mean that
that's it guys yeah at the end of the
day there's something about you know
it's like Otis Redding never really
showed a ton of range right you talk
about the acrobatics it's all right I
just wasn't someone who was you know
singing in all these same with Curtis
Mayfield yeah I'll fall said I'm all set
oh but it was like nobody else was doing
it bingo yeah and in you felt it and
that's the thing like but you I don't
think you can tell me a singer nowadays
that that emotes the way that Otis does
know there was a while where um what's
the guy I want some of you brought you
good LDN now Benjamin but C D angels not
liar right because the angel feels the
same way you know I think he feels the
same way X I got to see him recently it
was amazing he's amazing man but that
but he's a real musician yeah that's
what I'm sayin I saw him think he was
playing a Curtis Mayfield song at the
ten years ago at the tribute he just
comes out on the fender rhodes and just
starts doing you know playing a tune and
you just go like look at this [ __ ]
don't mean that guy i mean boo to that
record video oh come on to me is one of
the best records released and I mean the
long time I think every ten years or so
something like you guys or D'Angelo
oradell slips through yeah it gets
through and it goes here comes the R&B
soul soul band you know yeah and it gets
through and it's like there was there's
a time where they were trying to get
Joss Stone you know she ride they just
pounded that it never really stuck and I
think that had a lot to do with no songs
yeah my heart there was no songs there
yeah you know you have to have songs too
because biggest thing a lot of these
[ __ ] people can sing but they don't
know how to write songs how when you
guys went into right the first records
so you're coming from a cover band and
and then you and the bass players say
hey we're going to go to college but
let's track this demo how do you guys
write these songs do you never wrote
songs before riot Jesse Jesse had and we
had win me and him we started realizing
quickly with the first band that it was
like this is the relationship you know
this is we have a connection musically
and he we knew that and so he jessie is
actually a really good songwriter really
good and he you know he he you know
obviously like he's a used John Lennon
and Paul McCartney fans right like
obsessive with the Beatles yeah and just
a lot I mean just like he loved Elliott
Smith that was one of our killer you
know the main infinity tries what a song
but you don't to me that but elegant
isn't he understands songwriting he
understood to him that is that is the
pinnacle yeah it's like Jeff Buckley
yeah Elliott Smith there was these dudes
that were you know even Jeff Tweety
rocker he gets his yes I will go faster
yeah when you get into some beatles
flavor a lot of people even jellyfish
I've talked about it over and over
here's a band that understands multi
harmonies the way songwriting is you
know like happiness is a warm gun that's
like three [ __ ] song is yeah oh yeah
kind of stuff you know yeah Jesse Jesse
that's his that he that he is obsessed
with that and and and you know he's he's
been now Jesse's been a lot of bands
yeah he thought is he older than you oh
yeah yeah how old is it Jesse how old's
jesse he's like 90 or something light
he's a hundred seventy-six years old I
think I think he's I think I think he's
three or four years older than me right
so he's he's but he you know he loves
him he played in bands all his life he
was Jimmy I up junior I think yeah from
high always base no wow Jesse started as
the guitar player this man knows [ __ ]
that's what Jesse's that's just he's
like instrument of choice Wow it had to
be the other guy had to be like next
level then for him to sell was the thing
bro when bro and got involved you know
bro into play with Jason is bull and and
a lot of these a lot of these muscle
shoals folks yeah and we never went
broke oh yeah you know he knew broen and
he you know Jesse played but I had to
had played bass in other bands yeah I
mean he's just a great musician
he he um yeah he took a backseat which
was I mean that's interesting because
base is always looked at as like okay
the buffoon is on base but that's in the
rock world in the [ __ ] R&B world the
bass player is the god I mean you got to
talk about like Funkadelic boots Colin I
talked about like I said Lake saw all
the seventies bass player guys they were
the captain you know what's the one
guy's name uh Larry Carlton he's got the
microphone on his head on his bass right
there I mean Jamerson is you know with
Motown is up done Duk dong we actually
this last record duck Dunn's bass came
like they brought it to the recording
session all right it was incredible
candy apple red one I think so he plays
like getting up like that it was beat to
hell Wow it was amazing but it was like
it was it was like trying to wrangle a
wild stallion because I was just just
think block would and just yeah those
dudes back then they didn't understand
setting up their instruments though
we're gonna stay at all it's just
sometimes it wasn't even a case they
just grabbed it out and you pick it up
neo did the action on this is like eight
feels that seconds exactly yeah just the
fret the neck is just wrong and the
action is like eight feet off the base
as I go gooey cocaine sweat on it is
incredible yeah incredible but I mean
that's you know Jamison with Motown is
probably the one that all of us look at
I mean and then pino palladino also with
my horse do stud that that's the mean to
me that's the magic and if you don't you
have a what we do if you don't have a
good drummer and a good bass player you
ain't [ __ ] nope no better just cut it
out there so right yeah I'm still right
so that's that's that's where you get
that's where the magic has to happen its
rhythm rhythm section yeah I always
always say you know I show me a great
band and I'll guarantee it's a killer
drummer
epsilon judge gotta start with that it's
got to start with that and if it if it
begins and ends there yeah if it doesn't
I saw Ben last night I could blatantly
feel the drummer sewing down blatantly
yeah and I was like really man yeah I
mean come on dude yeah you're in a seat
that anyone would want you're slowing
down right I thought don't you feel that
you're drifting his mind's drifting or
something yeah only way that happens or
your bad German you're not a bad drummer
if you've got one of these high-profile
yes you shouldn't be shouldn't be not a
shimmy yeah there's some drummers out
there that are just [ __ ] unbelievably
good yeah yeah no I mean that's that's
what that for what we do if that that
lacks that's bad news when you start
getting the guys and you get in the
sound and you start playing gigs there's
got to be no one coming out right I'm
just saying that because it's so hard to
build a draw unless you're doing covers
or you're famous you know yeah like when
you're there there's got to be like 10
people well we first the first show we
ever played right do you know a lot of
friends is that what is those 100
degrees and there was about three people
who are outside now there's about three
or four people there all right but the
thing is I think what translated and
this is this is this is that you saw
these guys putting like a billion
percent into what they were doing and it
doesn't sound bad um I think I think we
I think we hit I mean it just grew it
just grew up anything else and but oh
yeah those first couple shows were
pretty rough and then the the one thing
we did do because we sat on half the
city for a while we couldn't release it
until till we waited a year Wow why is
that we just we well we did it the
everything started getting bigger than
we thought it would right and so then
you start going all right [ __ ] what do
we you know how do how does this work so
we got a manager and and okay just just
kind of with just sat on it for a little
while you mean the record company said I
with no no no they wanted to release it
immediately but we were just like whoa
hang on how does this work that's crazy
because if you take the risk of that
after a year you might be like a [ __ ]
those songs were way better now well
that's what happened haha knew it
what happened as you only have been four
months and you track a rescue is that
what it feels great cuz your new like
it's like new [ __ ] and yeah I got right
later on you my god this is old yeah
exactly that's exactly what happened is
that we we recorded that year you know a
year in advance and and by the time we
got I mean that was the things where the
live show took off so well because we
were better band reh a better we we
could have we could wrangle those songs
by the time that record came out but
your records not out are you out on the
road or how will people come out with
one record came out or new one came out
to Thurman I I know you're new one yeah
I'm saying oh that's the thing we have a
reputation in town Wow oh so you're just
trying in town is planning yeah we do
what we're doing we're doing we did we
did we got a booking agent involved in
that time period and and he put us out
opening and how do you get that [ __ ] in
Alabama a booking agent and stuff well
we didn't get it now yeah we got it in
Nashville I got okay got to say so you
we got we got fortunate got it actually
really what happened we got a phenomenal
manager no [ __ ] who is it names her
name's Tracy Thomas wow she she she
changed the game she sees you in we're
now as feeling that we played a damn of
it was a weird connection we had a
friend he was from Birmingham who's
booking this is called of music city
roots i had a lot like acoustic yeah
country stuff was she was bluegrass and
[ __ ] yeah they're like such a fan of us
she was such a fantasy like forced us on
the show Wow and and and our manager saw
that and then saw another clip and this
woman out in Nashville and she she she
was like is this for real yeah and she
knew our guitar player because she
manages Jason isabels well right and he
had played with her so or played with
him and so she cheat when she got
involved though the game changed because
she knew she's doing and so she
approaches you and says hey you guys
want to go next level yeah it's
interesting that a manager would know
how to work your style of music because
I know a lot of people would probably
look at yet powerful managers right and
go too much work tons of talent but what
am I going to put them Rio there's no
easy dollar here I'm out that's a lazy
manager right but somebody that really
understands the ins and outs of music in
the rooms across America and the the
weight of the game works yes I know
where to put these guys they're going to
be on Conan then I'll put them out here
with this band then maybe they'll play
with a like macy gray or say somebody
putting you into the audience's that
understand that kind of music yeah she
she was a so she was really good at what
she did and she still is and so when she
comes at you what are her ideas like she
says do you want to go next level and
what were some of the ideas well so the
thing for her it was really funny cuz we
acted like we like oh we got plain
meetings with other managers hmm and we
sure should yeah oh yeah oh yeah got so
many people coming at it yeah we met
with her wednesday they called her
friday like yep we're good yeah i mean
her whole idea is is a looking at the
show yeah and going this is for her in
her mind like this is this is st. think
shows like this yeah roaming around old
soul reveal yeah it's like that movie
The Commitments yeah once that movie was
a smash hit in the theaters because
people related with the the struggle of
these people right and how great the
music was right and it reminds them I
think people are so out of touch with
what is great that when they see you
they'll wow yeah oh [ __ ] yeah I think at
least for me is like the singing real
music in general when we've yeah and so
she devils her plans like put our ass on
the road and we I mean God I mean we
played over 200 shows and 2014 and we
don't we yes it's kind of a constant
thing and and kind of built from there
and she just knew she I don't know it's
it I don't know how she did but then we
got a got a great through her we got a
great booking agent right and he now he
and and he knows he's I mean you know he
he does Wilco you know you know Ryan
Adam
that s you know Stu's to you know what I
mean like things things that he real
musicians real music knows what how to
[ __ ] work that channel yeah like if
you like Wilco Orion you're going to
love son volt you're gonna watch st.
Paul you're writing love [ __ ] you
know all that stuff and he knew talks
yeah and he knew what he was doing and
and with those two I mean those two
combined it was uh it was just like we
would have had to really mess something
up yeah and they invest what we did we
just hit the road man when we played
shows that but it was that attitude for
playing in front of three people I don't
care give him the damn show of their
life make sure that they don't forget
you totally and and that's just with
this very old school that way go into
each market playing it feeling like
you're playing a gretsch don't ever
don't ever play it you know just no
punching it yeah yeah and so that's what
we did we and it just kind of built from
this very very old school in that
mentality that's how we sold records I
mean half the city i think sold over a
hundred thousand records and now
available that's unbelievable i'm brain
age say oh yeah yeah yeah especially you
know look at all the things against you
the style yeah the stealing of records
you know what I mean and then the no
single yeah you know the name yeah no no
hit single yeah course you had singles
but no yeah no you know here's here's a
big question I have for you because I
sang all my life and and and you're
incredible singer you get out on the
road now road singing is way different
than home and then off for a week
organics once you start you're out doing
2200 gigs in 2014 what starts happening
to your voice because you're a new
singer you've never told you don't
there's no handbook yeah do you start
immediately hire a guy to learn how to
warm up and warm down and all this are
you drinking like you know throw
cartoons getting ready not talking after
shows what's going on man I'm you know I
don't smoke and I don't drink yep
neither so those Lu things it helps yeah
however sleep is the number we piss
number one yeah sleep is number one and
I I you know I have to sleep that's
that's key in I don't you know I don't
all stay away yeah
in their monitors and we just went about
a couple months ago we moved an ear
monitors and it's yeah game changer yeah
oh especially falsetto fall so I was a
gamer like yeah like that [ __ ] and you
know that's false I mean all of that
that was a game changer and I just had
to learn yeah well also when you're
known as this powerhouse singer you'll
over do it all the time right take it
like just like all right on this one I'm
gonna [ __ ] show them you know right
broken bones a pocket right I just like
yeah you know you say I needed to go all
the way
you do realize that I mean there's some
nice what you feel like doing it you're
like I let's see how let's see how far
the rubber bank if this sound is good
yeah there's only the trickery of the
sound man you get into the sweet spot
you're like holy [ __ ] i'm on no let's
just go for ya oh there's nice like that
um but I mean you just I mean did you
get a guy though to start it's the only
the only thing I did I did I did a
session where I was like how do I keep
this yeah because I didn't think at
first I was like listen Toby it's like
who cares yeah yeah yeah but then you
realize you're like all right you're
gonna be playing you know we just
realized like all right you got radio in
the morning you gotta do a performance
there if you got you know just how to
we're at a good place now to where you
know we're not playing five shows in a
row and doing a radio each day or six
shows or however many cup um your guy
mean you're getting famous you're on
this show always oh yeah but so what do
you do you hired a guy and got some
vocal warm-ups just yeah just did some
warm up some warm downs um I never knew
heard of warm downs my old time singing
until I was hanging out with Cedric
bixler-zavala mean to me it's just it's
from what I was taught you just it's
just going back down you know you go
through the same thing you did move up
wow so lip trills ed like oh yeah and a
lot of stuff like that and loosening up
the voice and throat coat tea you do TV
yeah bad throat cut I love the taste of
it actually our tour manager has crazy
teeth awesome or hippies same one that
said or use like two runner ball does
have no idea special potion it's got
some sort of special potion yeah it's
great
and uh it's uh it is tricky it's it's
wearing a bus now yeah that's a
different ballgame so you can sleep
instead of an oh man I'd never forget it
we sleep in the back and it'd be hot as
hell and I just I'd wake up and feel
like I pissed my pants cuz i sweating so
much justice that's not know I I know
bands that do that and you got to that's
part of the process um but God as a
singer I mean there but to be fair we've
only had to cancel two shows our whole
time you had yeah add some that's up
well when I found out I have renewed
energy allergies I'll bad allergies so
cuz you've never been out of the out of
Alabama and also you getting them I'd
wouldn't have worried about saying yeah
you get yeah you get an Oklahoma like
what's this bush yeah actually [ __ ]
up my throat right now that's exactly
what I went through and I had so luckily
have a good E&T in Birmingham oh yeah
and he's got I don't have that you know
and had it many worries about it that's
great but I didn't know that you know I
thing are you like you're like what's
going on with me right now oh my god I
hate canceling should I was like crying
we click cancel the show in West
Virginia and I'm in the back just
bawling like I hate can't and managers
like I think West Virginia's gonna be
alright I hate it I hate it I cancelled
one gig ever in comedy and it was I got
ran over on a motorcycle yeah I did
comedy the next day and then after that
I was like I better sit down I was like
I got this vicodin tomorrow I don't even
get high so now I'm on stage I'm feeling
like [ __ ] you know like you know like
a 70s comic just all hell and that I'm
to waver in all slow I made a nun
process it as best she ever seen you do
I was like [ __ ] you man what can you say
the worst show you've ever done as a
stand-up you led to me none of them were
bad yes they're all you know they are
they're all not doing construction
you're damn right when I work I work out
I've worked for the the cut my dad works
for it's a go Fred of mechanic
a mechanic shopping yeah cutting grass
pulling the other thing cutting grass
[ __ ] Freeman house a house painter I
was you know landscaper hot upset you
damn right that don't miss that at all
what's that he can bring all the bad
gigs on you want to say I always how you
have to remember that you know you start
getting spoiled which we have we've got
and you know we just forgot I remember
it you got to remember it and so we do
every time we play show right before we
we talk about oasis pizza this is gig we
played yeah yeah it's a small town in
Tennessee and uh we say it every time
because you got to remember like this
one's for Oasis ppl ases pizza because
we we we got there we all kind of had a
bad attitude and kind of whatever that
one and we got in there and you know we
all got in there were like all right
we're gonna give him the show of her
life because it was one of those times
you could have just been like you know
this is kind of weird yeah punching
people people people playing eatin pizza
you know and you know where tender like
a saint heart yeah exactly Otis Redding
didn't [ __ ] place he's a giant he
play dominoes hey Dahlia we thought
about doing a pizza hut to her after
that but uh we went in there and I was
getting on top of the table all these
people eating and it was you could tell
you got him yeah you got him and like we
like don't ever don't ever forget that
yeah don't forget that then that's what
we do I know you got to get out of here
let's just talk to real a new record
real quick it's so funny I wanted to ask
you if it was your idea what because
they the press on it was they really
going for 70 s R&B sound here and I was
like where is that because seventies R&B
to me is over twin and five
I mean shinin star exile and stuff and
when I first spun the record I was like
a man na is so weird and that to me
means I'm gonna love this record cuz I
hated achtung baby when you to put it
out yeah and now it's [ __ ] one of the
crown jewels in my life but I spin the
record and his first single what does it
flex or what's this all I'll ever want
to flow with it the first songs on yeah
yeah and I was like yeah it's it's okay
and then like three listens in I was
[ __ ] hooked on this record yeah and
now I play it every I keep tweeting I
can't get enough of this record i will
be your woman is a [ __ ] smoking to
how fine but the track on this record
that really excites me for what you're
going to do next is track six sanks
what's it cost sanctify what the [ __ ]
did that song is now that thing is
almost a heroine soul song yeah read a
[ __ ] song what is that song about man
oh well me that song to me is just it's
all about sexualizing it's so good a
religion but but it's a man that song
that that's what i mean and what's crazy
is that that some kills live all I ever
thought it would yeah smokes on the
record but but bleep man that song to me
is a that exactly that's where it was
like this that's one that's one of songs
were like this is where it's going yeah
and we were just like all right this is
awesome and it was a it was a that one
man that was a jam session that happened
and jesse was doing that Oh Andrews
hitting the drums I was like I was like
guys I don't know what that is yeah
we're figuring out something with that
that's the [ __ ] future of Saint Paul
to me I feel like it is I really do
because I think when you listen to that
track he go there's this that's them I
cuz the eyes I don't say it's this I
don't say it's that I say that's you
guys I think that was the thing with
this and I think that's always the thing
of second regular is finding your voice
yeah cuz you know the debut record is oh
you know
influence yeah yeah yeahs a record
that's your statement yeah and and so
that one especially was like all right
this is where we're headed this is back
oh [ __ ] song is killer and then
there's a this one also let's see I
loved let's see I of course brain matter
oh yeah that's enough oh yeah what a
[ __ ] tune man this record has some
great [ __ ] songs only I think so yeah
I'm really proud of us man I mean for
real it's so funny because I put it on I
think that the press of 70 s RB really
threw me the wrong way because i love
70s arm be so [ __ ] much as I oh wow
this is cool the first one's kind of 50
60 s ya gonna be 70 s I'm ready for some
[ __ ] mouth I be exact lot of b3 you
know so exactly now you know maybe
up-tempo like get on up yeah get on up I
think it's gonna be that and I put it on
oh it's not that so I walk away for a
minute and then I go well if they didn't
pump it like that so I read put it on
like a weight this records better than
the first record yeah and now I just
can't I think that and always the prey
you know that's how they market [ __ ]
yeah is all you know I don't I don't add
to me it's like the way I view it is
typically not how the press is gonna
view it exactly yeah so I think they're
lazy yeah maybe they just go out 70s on
me and you don't really want where's
that at well it looks like a song like
brain matter where did where does that
fit on the 70s army not even for a
second he said I'm saying yeah and it's
fine but I just fine I always kind of
fight because they're like genres in
general yeah so just for record labels
yeah yeah [ __ ] that PR people you know
what I say great record what genre is
it's great yes the genre tomaters
there's great and [ __ ] yep exactly
that's that's what it is to me I can't
think enough for coming down man I
I've been a big fan since I saw that El
Rey cake I've been shot you know a
couple years now and I can't talk enough
about this if you look at my twitter
feed I've been [ __ ] bro and I'm
terrible at social media oh yeah i grok
I hope so I hope so we don't want your
frontman to be great at social it's like
Roland said a good front man is a guy
that can't do nothing but be a front man
that's another picture I'm of the job or
inning and that's the [ __ ] truth I
couldn't imagine up there going bro get
my old and pocket change and then you're
back here in the air between just killed
it out there I'm so bad at it I'm so bad
of course I was good at it you don't
want to be good at that you know I have
to be unfortunately because I'm a
community manager it yeah comedians
Manus that's it's the world that's the
world man it's the world but you know to
me I get the hot like I said I get the
hot behind other other people that's it
man I love you dude and what time you
guys on tonight eight o'clock or
something on a [ __ ] I don't know why
are you coming back through I'm sure at
some point yeah absolutely cuz the
record just came out yeah I want to go
back because I got [ __ ] gigs tonight
I know some one guy we can I glad I
can't it be here then yeah absolutely
look at but if you want it like really
like nine I can make it no problem well
Tommy gigs eight o'clock and midnight so
I can go to your gig here and I mean all
right we'll work it out well I gotta see
it cuz I'm gonna oh it's a minister
Lucius it's got the same energy but it's
and you're in the wiltern which is great
i can'twe great room thank you so much
new records called SIA noise and follow
these people on Instagram and Twitter
and tell people about this it's how good
art gets out there I'll spread the word
thank you so much for thank you man yeah
I love you did thank you right on man